Calculate the area of a
rectangular room that is 13
feet wide and 18 feet long.
So the room might
look like this.
We're looking at a floor plan.
So it is 13 feet wide and
it is 18 feet long.
So that dimension is 18 feet.
And when you're looking for the
area of a rectangle, you
literally just multiply
the two dimensions.
You multiply the width times
the length in this case.
So the area is going
to be equal to 13
times 18 square feet.
So let's multiply that out.
13 times 18.
Now we're first going to worry
about this 8 in the ones
place, right?
18 is really 10 plus 8.
So when we take this 8 in the
ones place, 8 times 3 is 24,
the 4 in the ones places.
Regroup the 2, which is really
a 20, or carry the 2.
8 times 1, now this 1 is really
a 10, so 8 times 1 is
8, plus 2 is 10, and there's
no other digits, so we can
write the whole 10 down here.
So we now see that 8
times 13 is 104.
Now let's worry about
the next digit.
Let us worry about this 1 right
here in the tens place.
Now since it's in the tens
place, we want to
put a zero down here.
1 times 3 is 3.
1 times 1, we ignore this 2.
That was from the other
digit so we ignore it.
1 times 1 is 1.
So you see that 8 times 13 is
104, 1 times 13, or we should
say 10 times 13, because
that 1 is in the
tens place, is 130.
18 is the sum of 10 and 8, so 18
times 13 is going to be the
sum of these two numbers.
So it's going to be
104 plus 130.
4 plus 0 is 4, 0 plus 3
is 3, 1 plus 1 is 2.
So the area of the room is 234
square feet, or you could call
it feet squared, however
you want to do it.
I'll write it like this:
square feet.
And if you're actually draw a
grid where you drew 18 lines
in this direction, if you kept
going, and 13 lines in this
direction, if you were to
count all the boxes,
you would get 234.